parent
question bonjour monsieur séguin ici
pour le film tarzan lajaunie oui les
porteurs et les indigènes c'est le
bureau d'à côté monsieur sais c'est pas
pour ça c'est celle agence artistique
abdou diouf du pdu qui m'envoient pour
le film de transit avant c'est à peu
près tout bas seuil et vous messieurs
merci mais je vous dis tout de suite
c'est pas possible
pourquoi ben parce que vous êtes comment
ça je suis enfin n'est pas dans
l'optique enfin droite dans l'atteinte
du personnage c'est ce pas on m'avait
dit un jour l'homme sage alors je
pensais que je pouvais en parlant de
saint julien et toutes les photos de
cheetah là oui oui c'est celle là qu'on
a sélectionné alors vous voyez il n'y
aurait pas assez de contrastes entre
vous et la même parce que vous soyez
venus la veille commerciale interne j'ai
fait j'ai fait qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai joué il ya deux semaines à pointe à
pitre les misérables les misérables
collaro vous teniez aime ce genre major
derrière velina simone rôle de cosette
roger combotte curriculum qu'est ce que
vous avez fait votre âge et fait de la
publicité ouais j'ai fait la pub on
compte le binz donc le nom c'est moi qui
fais chauffer de report j'ai fait de
bonnes grillades et je faisais de betty
versé à oui d'accord non on fait ça
c'est la publicité vous avez fait du
cinéma
oui je vais dans le rouge et noir ah bon
avec geronimo cochise dans le rôle du
oui j'ai compris j'ai fait la même
journée mot cochise dans une pipe de
fromage alors c'était le cas prise non
pas les publicités si vous voulez des
sorciers bon jeu peut à la rigueur vous
donner un rôle d'un type qui tombe d'une
falaise et qui se retrouvent dans une
mare à vis des crocodiles
il ya eu un accident vous avez été
déchiqueté dans gt coupé au montage
non franchement je peux pas vous donner
le rôle aucun sens parce que bon il
faudra forcer l'attelage allez vous
faudra tout changer et en plus on tourne
la nuit alors du mal pour vous garder
mais monsieur hees existe le maquillage
fluorescent quand même à la rigueur mais
enfin vous savez qu est-ce qui est
pressentie dans le rôle de jane au derek
monsieur bo derek voyait peut-être ma
méthode à sommer à l'assaut des photons
alors ça devrait être négatif
bo derek même avec ces notes est fait
pour africaine
moi je peux faire 15 ans et l'afrique
monsieur je me place à appliquer s'il
vous vient pas d'un problème enfin nous
allons vous êtes trop clair pour le
personnel et cheveux bruns mais juste le
bronze est vrai que des élus à la côte
d'azur à saint tropez second en deux
jours vous êtes peut-être les curieux
pas trop viable et maintenant alors oui
la production en algérie est la
production oui bonjour oui alors pour
leur de tarzan maintenant ces essais
c'est bon c'est ok alors c'est plus tard
ans la jolie site argent abondé un art
dans le rôle de tchita dans jane pour
les chiites a et pour cheetah d'accord
y'a pas de problème on va s'arranger au
revoir monsieur